I think it was the Ernstein Herrnstein
and Murray I think did the calculations
back in the bell curve that indicated
that if you imagine that you could,
you are a fairy godmother and you have
your newborn grandchild in front of you
and you can grant them three
standard deviations above the mean,
um,
in terms of wealth at birth.
Or you can grant them three
standard deviations above
the mean in terms of Iq at
birth.
And then you want it to determine which
would work better for them by the time
they were 40.
And the answer to that was quite clear
is that Iq Trump's wealth to right,
it'd be able to predict a positive future.
So that's why I'm so interested in the
concept of increasing Iq or increasing
the g factor,
not just the Iq score,
but really what under
this reasoning ability.
So you know,
some people have tried to teach
college students critical thinking.
Yeah,
I think that's a good thing.
You can get it and you can think
critically so much the better.
Exactly.
You know,
and you know,
it may sound to your listeners,
I just want to take a moment out here.
It may sound to your listener,
it's like,
here are these two guys pontificating
about what it's like to be smart,
what it's like to be not so smart.
I mean,
the point of this,
the point of neuro science research,
all intelligence.
So what I hope to achieve by writing the
book was to show that that the genetic
aspects are not deterministic.
It's the opposite.
So our probabilistic,
so the extent to which something
like an intelligence is genetic,
in my view,
is the extent to which we'll learn
how to change it for the battery.
Yeah.
Because people do tend to think about
biological factors is deterministic and
that that's a mistake
because they can be shifted.